today major league baseball proudly
celebrates roberto clementi day
the toronto blue jays are pleased to
recognize our team's nominee for the
roberto clemente award
blue chase manager charlie montoya will
now present beau with his award
congratulations bull robbie ray we're
trying to uh go a little bit deeper than
he did in his last start this is start
number 29 for robbie ray look at those
sparkling numbers 209 batting average
against 220 strikeouts in 173rd
in a third inning and the 2-2
and he got it he got him with a fastball
here's manuel margot
swinging a miss got another one and it's
another fastball he gets rid of a
rosarina with a fastball
and now he's going to take care of
manuel marco this time up and away
fastball change up occasional curveball
1-0 on the record very good era and very
little on the base running side of
things
laces it to left field and it's going to
be over the head of a rosarian and off
the fence
another
rocket off the bat of guerrero this one
stays in the ballpark and goes for a
double so second and third with a one
out and the rays are going to bring the
infield in here in the first inning
against beau bechet with number 21 on
his back he is the club's roberto
clemente award nominee for this season
one two again
another change-up and he wallops it to
left field and it's gone
he was all over it number 25 on the
season for beshet three to nothing blue
jays well that's how you let that ball
come to you you make sure he gets it in
the strike zone and then go attack it
three nothing blue jays top two here's
brandon lau the second baseman
got him with a fastball away for out
number one third strikeout for ray
already on the afternoon and that'll
bring up mike zanino
struck him out
two down two down in the inning five out
so far for ray four of them have been
strikeouts
got him
again 96 up in the zone
you are watching one of the game's best
at his craft here this season five
strikeouts he strands the lead off
double at second base
murders gurio jr puts it into play on
the ground to short
walls throws them out brando grichik
that's deep short
long throw for walls it's right there
well this is exactly what walker's
looking for two pitches two outs blue
jays
and he is out on strikes blue jays
leading 3-0 taylor walls brett phillips
and then randy arose arena
ground ball down to third right at lamb
and walls retired now here's the number
nine hitter brett phillips 02 swing and
a miss brett phillips overmatched by
robbie ray strikeout number six
1-0 there's a swing at a fly ball down
the right field line hernandez into a
sprint running off near the line
crossing into foul territory making the
catch the blue chase leading at three
nothing george springer at the plate and
he gets the strikeout there
out front and some dip to that one so a
man on for guerrero
this one is lined to left center field
and it's off the wall on a bounce
simeon's going to be held at third
another ringing double for vladimir
guerrero jr so same situation for beshet
as it was back in the first second and
third one out
and it's up
fly ball to right this will be deep
enough to get a run home
simeon will tag and score gladial tag
and come to third four to nothing
well in the second inning the rays had a
leadoff double it was yandy diaz and
then robbie ray struck out the next
three batters
swinging a miss to get him number seven
already for robbie ray a great slider
there run over third one out four
nothing blue jays in the fourth
and it's popped up in foul territory
kirk's got to play two down so margot
stands at third now two out pitch
swinging a mess he got him with a slider
strikeout number eight for robbie ray
and once again he works around a lead
off double alejandro kirk leads it off
after the first pitch on the ground
and that ball
well a nice play there
taylor walls going deep into the hole
and making a nice throw promise you love
the shed is powered blue chase in front
four nothing here he steps in delivers
3-2
swinging a high fly ball into left
moving back guriel to the edge of the
warning track to the wall jumps up gone
home run
mike cenino for the first time in his
career has hit 30 home runs and the
razor on the board 401 that definitely
was one of those helium homers
i followed that home run from the time
it left the bat to the point where
it looked like it was would have almost
hit the roof
had it been closed here
this afternoon and then just kept on
going and backspinning and backspinning
until it finally just dropped over the
wall so it's runners on the corners for
beau bechet who has driven in all four
runs for the blue jays today
up the middle
the shet hustling down the line beats it
out for an infield hit and he's now
driven in five runs on the afternoon
couple of men on now for t oscar
hernandez over two to center field this
ball is going to drop
blatty around third and in to score rbi
single hernandez it's six to one out of
the order randy rosarino will lead off
the sixth against robbie ray
again a nasty down and in sliders
strikeout number ten two balls and two
strikes on nelson cruz the 2-2 pitch
swing and a miss robbie ray is back at
it again
adding to a double-digit strikeout total
give him 11.
robbie ray having another great
afternoon six innings just one run has
not walked about or has struck out 11.
got him on three pitches and now ray has
struck out every batter in the raised
lineup at least once
he's going to go right after him again
popped up shallow center
and what a catch
randall grichik racing in
and making a great play for the second
down outstanding play by grichik for the
second out of the inning nobody loving
it more than robbie ray two down now
here's jordan luplow oh for two rudder
at first the one-two pitch swinging a
miss
he struck him out a baker's dozen for
robbie ray
13 strikeouts through seven superb
innings let's see if rey's can make
things interesting here lead off man
aboard here in the eighth and now brett
phillips the batter
he swings and shoots it into deep center
field
kritchik will watch that one and it is
gone home run
brett phillips has connected for the
12th time this year
and suddenly
the race put two on the board and that
makes it 6-3
it will be zenino
simeon is there
and the blue jays winning
[Music]
you